[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
do
[Music]
shooters
oh
foreign
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is our first year of bringing you
the very
best of what video games have offered
lots of changes at the evolver since the
last time we were here
old outdated irrelevant straight busted
i've got something better
today is only the beginning
the future of video games and the
futures
future future
i don't give a [ __ ] freak about
stupid live video game events hello
i need you to help me stop the features
feature features
comment on a million million strings
what's next
so then you know we kind of wrap it up
after that i'm thinking it's like a
four five year deal
ah i mean huh right
i think it's [ __ ] garbage [ __ ] [ __ ]
garbage i mean it's a dumb idea
that'll never work and you're an [ __ ]
for thinking it up who thinks this [ __ ]
it was me
uh i thought [ __ ] thinks this [ __ ] up
we're not doing a four-year-long series
of narrative videos about the futures
features whatever the [ __ ]
volvo digital cinematic youtube [ __ ]
your
[ __ ] face that was supposed to be me
right
my face is that even legal all devolver
digital new hires release holy any work
like miss attribution and slash or image
rates upon
execution of an employment contract
clear as day basically we can do
whatever we want with your likeness
even if it is some stupid video
abomination or whatever enough
enough of this you less talking more
typing you i don't like it the internet
would never buy it
we produce video games video games at
devolver digital and damn good ones
i'm told no get the hell out of my
conference room and take your dumb movie
idea with you yeah but listen it's not
just a dumb movie idea it's a
multi-layered narrative
universe you you don't understand this
is art this is this is painting with
light this is
cinema
well lesson slimes it is a goddamn white
hot arms race out there a hype e-type
media field intimidation game of boss
mode
knuckle [ __ ] nut kick and we are falling
away the mother effing emma [ __ ] behind
melissa do the numbers yeah so bad
people
real type bad we need a fresh
perspective
something wild something stunning
something new but not too new but new
enough so that it seems new to those
know it all know nothings in the no you
know
actually ma'am i think no no no record
scratch
what who are you and why are you making
noises at me
nina man uh nina strothers i'm an
adjunct under executive on the marketing
team
i'm gunning for synergy officer one day
why are you pouring the coffee
because we need coffee grab it hack jaw
nina
is it put the coffee down and talk at my
face
well uh uh the thing of it is
um a few of us were talking and
monetization as a service see
what he said that's gotta be the most
ridiculous let's [ __ ] do it
for four decades and counting devolver
digital has been at the absolute leading
edge of
technical social and humanitarian
progress in the burgeoning videotainment
market
now that's no accident the global
research and development teams at
evolver digital incorporated have worked
tirelessly to deliver
to you the unwatched consumers so many
breakthroughs in the video game
entertainment's fear that it's arguable
as to whether the countless problems
we've successfully solved were ever
actually problems
in the first place devolver earliest
access delivered games to the
marketplace at the exact point of
conception
a developer even thinks of an idea and
that shit's all ready for sale
to fall for digital screen pay allow
loudmouth consumers to not only throw
money at their screens
but to throw money at our federally
unregistered offshore corporate bank
accounts
revolver even jumped ass first into that
cryptolight though broth before electric
car parents made it all the rage
with loot box coin the markets first and
just the faculty last physical
cryptocurrencies that lived entirely off
of the blockchain
you're blam
last year we spent money we didn't even
have to fill the board shop huge when
you mad thirsty consumer soul when ethan
was canceled
the volvo land exposure revolutionized
the very concept of marketing
as the industry's very first quadruple a
playable video game trade show that you
can download and play as a video game
and
video game play as a video game progress
can't be stopped though no
so this year devolver digital is taking
aim at the blisteringly lucrative
subscription service video game market
welcome to developer pass plus
hmm welcome to the future
games as a service a razor-edged
industry shuck dive that has served to
convert what was
traditionally a one-time purchase into a
potentially
lifelong chain ball commitment to
reoccurring payments for video games
that
let's be real deal about this most of
you don't even enjoy anymore
[Music]
devolver likes to take things further
dive the big dive you know take the leap
push the envelope
towed the wet sprocket go big or go home
and baby
we ain't got no home to go home to
devolver likes to take things to a place
that isn't even
funny so much is creepily possible
and uncomfortably prescient
that is why monetization as a service
we see it as a groundbreaking new way to
keep consumers
locked into a semi-regular non-payment
schedule with a
novel if not needlessly complex approach
where in a top-tier service subscriber
that is you
look at you is granted access to dozens
if not hundreds of dozens
of premium purchases at the low low
monthly price of no cost to you
for the subscription itself hit me again
[Music]
that is the max pass plus difference you
simply apply and your credit competency
work history
genealogical stray factor total lunar
payload weight
environmentally induced super selection
state and very first
magic deck are evaluated on a 29 point
density matrix
and boosh you're absolutely rose street
[Music]
from there you are granted direct access
to purchase anything in our constantly
growing collection
of video games and video game related
junk
for free
[Music]
well well not the purchases they're not
free that would be insane
but access to those purchases though
totally freezies
[Music]
let's well let's
check a look at some of the video games
that amazing consumers
like you can look forward to if you get
approved of course
with the volvo max pass
[Music]
premium purchase
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
premium purchase
huh
so
fashionable now that's a phrase
a phrase that goes lock stock hand in
hand with gamers
an exclusive state of being if you will
to which only the most
jointly premium amongst us could ever
truly endeavor
to gain entry until now
no no no that's this not this
i'm snapping damn it being fashionable
is a natural extension of the devolver
max pass plus premium purchase
experience
brought from us to you by devolver's own
central textile manufacturing and
webinars branding entity subgroups
we would like to present to you our
newest collection of exclusive
garmentary
only available to the devolver max pass
plus survivors i mean
subscribers no hi shut up
this collection of fashionable
comfortable and catastrophically
unaffordable formal wear was designed
and manufactured entirely in-house by an
elite selection of our most popular and
attractive interns to whom we've given
key action words and access to an
internet connected device and
shall we say schwartz you may go
as with everything else in this
presentation the devolver max pass plus
exclusive merch collection is well
exclusive only available to subscribers
in a premium purchase not at all in the
subscription fee you may or may not but
maybe may be paying fashionable
am i right now let's take a deep breath
and take a peek at these two premium
purchase products that will be available
to you soon the adoring
devolver max pass plus survivor
subscriber oh man
yay
[Music]
premium purchase
is
got a thousand miles
[Music]
it's just
[Music]
cast
[Music]
so
away
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
premium purchase
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
since 1975 devolver digital and the many
incredible developers we've partnered
with have produced what can only be
appropriately described as
an imperial butt load of incredible
games
that consumers worldwide have purchased
never actually played
and then made public claims about the
game's quality in order to substantiate
their place in online conversations
about whether or not an indie game is
still
indie if it has a publisher
[Music]
that's why we're proud to announce the
entire devolver digital catalog on steam
is available at devolver max pass plus
as a premium service
not including your reoccurring monthly
payments that we still haven't quite
nailed down yet
each of these gems will be available at
a reduced rate for a bafflingly limited
amount of time
with discounts ranging from i why not
[ __ ] me why are my pants wet
think of it as a kind of thank you from
an old friend
an old friend that believes you deserve
a premium experience
visit devolvermatchcastplus.com for
more information
[Music]
premium purchase
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
premium purchase
hey kids do you love video games
i'm a grown man what are you doing in my
bathroom do you love video games
yes i play them quite a bit do you want
to pay for video games
not at all no what if you could play a
game for free but then later we charge
you for cool stuff and make you watch
ads for minimal benefit to you the
consumer
well that doesn't sound great pick up
your phone it's tumble time
ignore loved ones
reprioritize your life
[Music]
let it consume your very beginning
[Music]
turn real money into pretend money and
spend it
[Music]
collect your favorite characters that
you've never even heard
[Music]
devolver tumble time is the future of
physics-based puzzle gameplay
elegant monetization and strategic brand
integration
choose characters from a loaded roster
if you devolve a digital face and rack a
major huge big time game points by
matching and clearing the impossibly
adorable heads on the tumblr
we mentioned that it's free right
because it's free
except for the ads part with their ads
because of course their ads because
nothing has ever been free get hype and
unleash
each character's special move and clear
chunks
by creating and activating chaotic chain
reactions
pre-register for devolver tumble time on
the app store and google play by
visiting devolver tumbletime.com
hey
nina
[Music]
oh hey
let's talk about subscriptions for a
moment
the subscription service is an
instrument of monetization from days
gone
when your grandparents wanted to try a
new cheese each month and
your uncle wanted to look at photos of
naked ladies from the comfort of his own
tool shed
a relic an unwieldy physical beast
that we have haphazardly let slip into
the digital realm leaving us with
nothing but ones
and zeroes to stand in for our stinky
dairy product imperfect knockers
devolver though aims to return
subscription-based addiction
back to its more tangible roots with a
premium purchase title available only in
this
the physical plane of actual real for
real existence
is that god damn right it is introducing
demon throttle by developer doing soft
the creators of gato roboto
it's coming to the nintendo switch as a
physical box set and only
a physical box set through our good
friends at special reserve games
oh you heard me right demon throttle
will
not i repeat will not be available
in any digital format and is only
available for you
to purchase as a retail product and put
on your shelf and to never play or to
sell at ridiculous scalper prices to
anyone who missed out on its initial
offering starting
today
[Music]
check a look
premium purchase
[Music]
or something
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
demon bottle
huh i mean yeah
right i love it it's good really good
great work stilts
well it wasn't a thunk big moves by a
guy from where are you from
technically i'm not supposed to be here
okay now bring it home
hit me with the big move what's the
punch there
isn't one he does not videotapes
nina well tate what she said what's this
now
well we put the entire thing
on a tape and then sell it
like like this right
right here
videotapes the trick
though is that there is one and only one
and we
sell it to one buyer we put only the
entire thing just the one on the tape
just the one just the one sell it okay
and since there's only one and the buyer
keeps it and we broke the little tab on
the inside so you can't copy it
it is non [ __ ] with a bowl here
a non [ __ ] with the ball tape right nft
for short it's okay
it's going to be a thing can we do this
can this be done
it's it's actually already been done
okay the one copy of this entire
presentation
on tape the one in this player right
here is available online
for the first devolver max pass plus
triple platinum elite gold star magnum
double xl tier subscriber to go to
devolvermaxpassplus.com
and buy it okay it is it is totally
non-bulk livable it does does no damage
to the environment to the
energy grid or the the global technology
supply chain because it is
it's just i mean it's just this old tape
right
that that caleb found in in a in
a box mark nancy's batshi's hey in the
back of an old filing cabinet in the
birthing wing and it's
it's also a tape [ __ ]
brilliant yes yeah
zayn nina margaret caleb
this is such a wonderful
what the [ __ ]
a savage view another me stepping
back to reality another you
and now i'm free so let's get down with
this
[Music]
max pass
[Music]
is
[Music]
my lunar payload weight is
the catalog is super fast
[Music]
everything's been monetized you lost the
game the moment you
subscribed epilogue
max pass plus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mom i just finished
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you